die bundesregierung hat die temperatur
grenzen der arbeitsstätten richtlinie
geändert um schnell kommen heizsaison
signifikant gas zu sparen auch die
regelungen in mietverträgen über eine
mindesttemperatur werden vorübergehend
ausgesetzt was kommt da auf uns zu wenn
man erst mal 19 grad denkt man sich na
ja worüber regt man sich denn überhaupt
auf aber was passiert denn eigentlich
bei weniger als 20 grad raumtemperatur
mit uns viele menschen fangen an zu
frieren bei 18 grad besteht sogar die
gefahr sich zu erkälten auch kann sich
schimmel in den räumen bilden frierend
für den frieden ist das motto dieser
tage doch ich finde dass es alles andere
als solidarisch 20 prozent müssen wir
als gesamt volkswirtschaft einspannen
energie um sicher durch den winter zu
kommen gasspeicher werden gerade voll
gemacht auf der anderen seite braucht es
auch leistungen mir schon klar dass
natürlich jetzt der einfache bürger das
nicht in erster linie schultern kann
aber natürlich büros wirtschaft
entsprechend die sollen das machen und
die ein oder andere maßnahme die nicht
bequem erscheint die muss auch kommen
weil wir müssen dieses ziel erreichen 20
prozent wir haben die krise